hello and welcome to this video playing
utter Roxas who is that no name ok yeah
I hope this session will be a bit better
than the one yesterday that was really a
powerful session probably it also wasn't
very entertaining to watch if you feel
like that I apologize yeah it was a damn
hot day yesterday and I couldn't get I
simply couldn't get my mind working at
all so I hope this is going to be a
better today it's a modern been only
here and let's see what utter Rock says
is so it's going for I think this set up
here with lie 2 g-3 is a very testing
one for black I think one issue who
black is that the white center is so
well protected and I counterplay often
it's not not that clear not that obvious
I came mm-hmm therefore this night 2h7
this is probably not good
not quite sure there are a number of
ways of playing this kind of position
sometimes what gets to play without air
three but I'm not sure here check
hmm bit surprised that he's taking time
here I thought just going back probably
I mean you don't want to trade the
bishop that would be quite surprising
maybe it's trying to decide where to put
it to f6 or to chess Evan he's taking it
Wow but it usually is Sir frankly
speaking completely enter positional
okay
and white plan is very easy with our
four and so on so let's see what to do
is probably playing a show anyway so I'm
going to put the night to have to be
five mmm sorry it's not yet that's right
okay my this position is very nice for
why I've got the Queen side safely
blockaded and it will be very difficult
for him to avoid each five both probably
impossible ef5 is also interesting his
bishop has nose and let's do it
really don't see ways putting the bishop
mmm also
just Knight takes e4 is also winning
here and let's do that it's probably
even better than taking the bishop so I
thought 95 but Knight f6 is also strong
and I t24 also hmm okay I'll go for that
if seven is under attack yaquina Forza
is one more Queen default is going to be
six at least and I can take up sexy
sister third possibility what clinic for
was my original idea Queenie seven hooky
one
you
you're just not if seven was my idea
oops check it was an unlucky pre-move
black resides I don't know night f7
Esther was natural move anyway yeah I
don't know okay so let's go back I think
a couple of things we're really
surprising um okay to be perfectly
honest I just think that white is better
here anyway but i think that i doing the
trade is just just a strange decision I
mean black could could go back when it's
still quite normal quite normal game
check after this I think white is just
clearly better without the dark squared
Bishop black skin position is a constant
problem yeah I have f4 and ultimately
five gambiae five this is very
comfortable now it's funny the computer
is giving this as only a slight edge for
white this I don't understand it wants
to play Queen to be six th one rokade
yeah well this is better than the game
but still this is a good position for
white Bishop f3 rupee 1e5 ok now the
evaluation is also climbing up okay yeah
so I think I hear the bishop is strapped
until ok I can take I mean I saw that
have the check yeah but still I mean it
isn't really it doesn't really matter
this is also win
so like black and snow diferencia f7 is
hanging the engine gives f5s the best
move yeah this is this is still looking
some somewhat tough group here right it
gives like plus 2 we have it so that has
to be played I will 96 for sure clean it
was even stronger here that's a nice
move check okay but this is also usually
better that Concetta gives this as the
best defense and now night 26 you know a
text and say what's check and this yeah
okay plus plus 6 is enough yeah I'm
really very skeptical about exchanging
the dark squared bishop and the Bologna
I mean I think without that piece that
opening becomes very very sorry that
structure becomes very very
unquestionable okay well thanks for
watching